Sean Hannity and Vivic ramaswami had an
interesting debate last night uh
ramaswami is is getting some heat from
some on the right um as I mentioned
because of his his stance on the Israel
situation but his stance to me is
totally reasonable he condemned the
attacks U I haven't listened to every
single thing he said about it so if he
said something horrible or delusional or
deranged about the situation in Israel
uh I haven't heard it all I've heard him
say is that is to condemn the
attacks um say Israel has every right to
defend itself but he wants to avoid
World War I and he and he doesn't want
America to needlessly get
involved and potentially make the
situation worse and bring in other world
powers and then you have World War I
which is also my stance happens to be
correct I think but even if you disagree
with it for some reason I mean even if
you think that uh that America should
put boots on the ground even if you are
with Lindsey Graham let's go bomb Iran
um you should still admit that the
ramaswami approach the non- intervention
approach it's at least reasonable and
rational and worth taking into
consideration it's not a crazy point of
view uh yet some Republicans are quite
mad at him including Shan Hannity and I
want you to listen to a little bit of
this exchange um between Hannity and
ramaswami
listen needs to be a party where if your
campaign is principally being run by
super Pacs people can give unlimited
amounts of money to your campaign I
don't think that befits the Republican
party I think we need to be better than
that so Sean you and I may have a
different but my view is if you're
making money off your time in government
then I don't think you're fit to be
president of the United States more
importantly though what's our policy
stand with our allies while avoiding
World War II and that's where I'm at a
lot of people don't think you're
qualified because you weren't even a
Republican or voting Republican until
what
2020 well Sean
I jectives with this interview are I
voted libertarian in my first election I
voted Republican in 2020 you're right
I'm not a partisan hack I come in from
the outside for independent minded
patriot who speaks sounds to me like you
just want to jump from the from the
private sector yourself where you made a
lot of money by the way I applaud
capitalism I applaud successful
people people work in in the defense of
our country and the defense industry are
playing a vital Ro for the RO role for
the cause of freedom so I don't really
call it a corrupting influence or
suggest that somehow that's a corrupting
influence I actually like the experience
goes contractors but I've got a listen
one of the things I loved about that
interview with Tucker one of the things
I loved about interview with Tucker was
we were actually able to have a
thoughtful conversation and go deep
into
kindala the point is
this go on these interviews yeah I I
have nothing but nice things to say but
here's your problem
go on these shows people quote your
exact words and you deny your own words
pause it uh I do love the fact that uh
VC brought up his interview with with
Tucker Carlson that was great uh
enforcing I think that's the F that's
that's got to be the first time since
Tucker left that anyone at Fox has even
said his name that anyone has openly
acknowledged his existence and said his
name and it's great that the person who
uh says his name is Sean Hannity Sean
Hannity who pretends to like Tucker
Carlson but I think we all I mean you
could even you could tell when Tucker
was there just the handoff between the
two uh Sean Hannity could barely contain
his
discust with tuo Carlson but putting
that
aside I I will say on Sean and Hannity's
part that you know takes a lot of
Courage I think we should applaud his
courage and his boldness uh to speak up
for the uh you know for marginalized
communities uh to speak up for people
who are really victims uh the powerless
in our in our world and in this case
he's speaking up for defense contractors
and career
politicians I applaud defense
contractors they defend
Freedom this is here's what I love about
Sean Hannity and I would use the word
love and I mean the opposite of it but
uh he
his he's just been saying the exact same
thing since like
2002 but it's not the kind of
consistency that you applaud okay it's
not it's not the kind of consistency
where where you say well he stuck by his
principles now it's
just basic you know early
2000s
neocon establishment Republican talking
points and he just sticks to no matter
what happens he he sticks to them they
don't
change and it's only ever talk talking
points have you ever in your life this
is a Ser I mean this is a sincere
question um Sean Hannity has been on air
for I don't know 25
years have you ever heard him offer
anything approaching an actual Insight
have you ever heard him say
anything even remotely interesting have
you ever heard him off offer something
that that sounds like an actual thought
and isn't just talking points that he
printed out from uh from the RNC have
you ever heard that have you ever
thought to one time I mean in 25 years
have you ever thought to yourself wow
Sean Hann made a great point Have you
ever heard have you ever said to someone
else or heard them say to you you know
uh Hannity had a great Insight the other
night it was and then they have you ever
heard that never never it's a kind of
it's an amazing again consistency not
not a consistency that we applaud not
the kind of consistency we applaud but
it's it's still an amazing consistency
that he's been talking for 25 years and
is never said one interesting thing you
would think that in 25 years of talking
you would accidentally say a few
interesting things and he never has you
know every Halloween you hear about the
dangers in the candy that your kids will
get which is why if you're a loving
father like myself you eat half of the
candy so that you can mitigate those
dangers to your child but this year you
know the real tricks are in the meat
aisle good ranchers wants to take the
trick out of your meat and they're
throwing in a treat for my listeners for
$30 off your order with promo code Walsh
at goodranchers.com
lab grown meat is growing more and more
popular foreign meat can be labeled as a
product of the United States and the
MRNA vaccine development is on the rise
for agriculture what's in your meat is
even more in question than ever before
amidst these haunting truths the real
hero arises good ranchers the number one
place to get America's best pork beef
Chicken and Seafood is with good
ranchers and they deliver it right to
your door their products are
transparently sourced All-American and
delicious when you shop at
goodranchers.com you don't have to
question what's in your meat or where
your meat is coming from you already
know they have a 100% American guarantee
and a transparent vaccination policy
take the mystery out of the meat Isle
visit goodranchers.com and use my code
Walsh to get $30 off with free express
shipping on your box of America's best
meat and seafood today that's code Walsh
for $30 off your box today at
goodranchers.com American Meat delivered
it's it is very similar to as we've
marveled before over someone like Trevor
Noah who was on air for for he wasn't he
wasn't on air for as long as Sean handy
but still he was on air for six or seven
years in a comedy show never managed to
say one funny thing and that was also
pretty impressive so it's kind of a
similar similar situation
um so what do we hear from Hannity there
he's sticking up for defense contractors
and career politicians and and uh and
he's also
implying that VC is unqualified because
he's coming from the private sector God
forbid God forbid he had a real job and
he's been out in the private sector he's
had success there and now he wants to
you know and and and now he's entering
politics um so he's getting
attacked uh for that and also for not
voting Republican in the
past
which like who does that remind you of
does that remind you of a politician a
current politician who Sean Hannity has
is has professed himself to be a big big
fan of and big supporter of for years
now
like Donald
Trump Donald Trump got into politics he
he was not a career politician he was
came out of the private sect he came
from the private sector right into
running for president same thing for
ramas Swami and um he was Voting not
just libertarian but voting
Democrat um up until the the few years
before he ran for
president you don't hear Sean Hannity
criticizing Trump for that do you
but the real issue here even putting all
that
aside the real issue is like what is
what's the problem exactly with what V
has said about the situation in the
Middle
East is again unless he said something
that I haven't heard that was that's
truly uh
crazy um all I've heard from him is just
listen uh what happen is terrible
condemn it it's awful it's evil Israel
has to defend
itself um in the United States of
America we have to continue always to
put our own security put our own people
first
always because this this is our country
and the people that run our country are
supposed to be representing our people
and so we have to put our people first
and uh what that means is not that we
don't care about what's happening to the
people doesn't mean that we don't
condemn evil when it occurs any
elsewhere in the world it just means
that we can't do something um that's
going to needlessly put our own People
In Harm's Way or harm our country in
some other way that's
it not only is that not controversial
but that is actually the
Baseline position that every American
should have and certainly every American
politician should have and that Baseline
position doesn't mean that we never go
to war under any circumstance like I
don't think anyone's saying that there's
never been a Justified war that
America's been involved
in it's just a matter of what are our
priorities and are we going to be
cautious and
thoughtful or are we going to be lindsy
Graham just running over there and
bombing everybody if You' like to see
what else I have to say you can access
my full show by going to dailywire.com
or by going to the Matt wall Show
Twitter page hope to see you there God's
me